é é um imenso prazer estar aqui
compartilhando com vocês nossas idéias
vendo essas palestras maravilhosas
desses tipos de escolha e o que me traz
a falar com vocês é justamente as
escolhas profissionais que eu tive que
fazer as escolhas profissionais que eu
fiz para chegar aos dias de hoje
algumas escolhas que a gente faz na vida
podem ser mais fáceis subir a escada
mais difíceis
andar pelo caminho mais plano pode ser
algumas escolhas boas ou algumas
escolhas ruins
algumas escolhas a gente poderia dizer
que são induzidas em conseguir a
apropriada as por outras pessoas para
nós
há algumas escolhas inconseqüentes e
quando eu me encontrava lá pelos meus 14
anos eu fiz algumas escolhas que eu
tinha certeza que as escolhas eram
minhas e só minhas eu não tinha sido
induzida não tinha sido levado a tomar
essas escolhas
doce ilusão que aos 14 anos eu teria
plena consciência de que o que eu queria
ser na vida era técnico em eletrônica
que eu não teria sido influenciada por
ninguém para fazer essas escolhas
não pelo fato de a escolha se á a escola
será uma quadra na minha casa do meu pai
já ter passado por aquela escola do meu
primo porque lá tinha estudado e pra
época era algo muito almejado trabalhava
na petrobras não tinha os rolos de hoje
né
minha irmã estudava lá eu tinha a não
tinha sido influenciada por ninguém a
escolha era minha
eu me pergunto na seria possível ter
feito outra escolha seria possível ter
feito uma escolha diferente para aquele
momento
ainda mais se a escolha era pela
instituição que tinha a fama na época de
que se trabalha lá naquela escola vai
ter o emprego garantido e para aquela
época também essa escola prometia formar
para a profissão do futuro técnico em
eletrônica bom em 1998 39
estava informada técnica eletrônica com
uma certeza não queria trabalhar com
eletrônica e nessas questões e nessas
escolhas da vida surgem outras
possibilidades de fazer algumas escolhas
não tão próprias e não com as minhas
certezas talvez naquela categoria de
escolher induzida como técnico em
eletrônica era uma profissão nova
eletrônica era uma profissão que estava
se constituindo a sua oportunidade de
trabalhar na escola
no nível técnico dando seqüência a
trabalhar com eletrônica porque não
trabalhar essa escola
afinal continuava sendo perto da minha
casa continuava sendo o ambiente
dominado não ia encontrar novidades
nesse sentido né e não precisava
trabalhar com eletrônica na empresa que
era isso uma certeza que eu tinha me
parecia mais razoável poder trabalhar
com eletrônica na escola e eu no mesmo
ano 1989 então eu comece a trabalhar
nessa escola como auxiliar de ensino do
curso de eletrônica no cargo de técnico
é aquele a que aquela pessoa que auxilie
o professor nas aulas práticas caminho
esperado de quem faz um técnico em
eletrônica para dar sequência na sua
formação seria fazer uma engenharia em
eletrônica fazer uma agenda é uma
ciência da computação engenharia
elétrica
mas eu já tinha decidido e essa é uma
certeza que eu tinha eu não queria isso
para mim não é esta área
então é mais uma daquelas possibilidades
de escolhas que vão aparecendo ea gente
vai tomando porque tem que viver tem que
dar conta da vida surge a novamente
ainda com essa questão da eletrônica ser
uma profissão nova que estava se
constituindo existia falta de docentes
em algumas áreas e nesta área uma delas
então surge um convênio entre a unisinos
o governo do estado ea fundação liberato
pra fazer uma licenciatura que é chamado
o esquema 2 que a licenciatura para quem
já tem um nível técnico então estava eu
em 1992 formada
licenciada em eletrônica uma graduação
e agora em 1992 foi o ano que eu casei
então já estava casada casa própria o
emprego estável o emprego uma
instituição reconhecida mas faltava
alguma coisa
eu não me sentia completo tinha algo ali
que estava me incomodando um filho não a
recém-casada 22 anos muito cedo para ter
um filho
e nessas andanças da vida indo trabalhar
eu passo pelo meio antiga escola e à
minha antiga escola eu comecei a
relembrar as coisas que lá eu fazia e
uma das coisas que eu fazia lá e que eu
gostava era jogar andebol e
relativamente eu jogava bem
jogava bem que até participava de
algumas equipes e algumas seleções para
aquela época na bom porque não dá
seqüência a uma coisa que eu gostava que
era atividade física
eu tomo uma nova decisão vou fazer
pessoa física e fui para a área de
educação física
fui fazer educação física e em uma nova
etapa na vida qual a universidade cursos
a fazer o vestibular novamente enfim
iniciar um novo curso em 94 e 98 foi
apresentada ao tal do tc e uma
apresentação tanto quanto surpreendente
inusitada digamos assim porque quem nos
deu as cadeiras etc era uma professora
que vinha de pára-quedas da espanha do
seu doutorado
pense numa pessoa empolgada agora
triplica
essa foi a professora que pegou esses
formandos para trabalhar com a
disciplina de tcc né
e ela dizia pra gente e ela começou a
apresentar para nós vocês vão fazer uma
pesquisa de tcc
vocês não vão fazer uma revisão tem hora
vocês vão fazer uma pesquisa dela começa
nos apresentar o que é como é que é
porque se faz
onde quando e ela dizia pra gente vocês
têm que ler lei dele nem escrever e
escrever e escrever e escrever ea gente
literalmente se sentia abraçado pelas
letras e pelos livros
mas imagina dizer isso conformando de
educação física sabe o que se diz os
formandos
ao final dos formandos mas o estudante
de educação física ou pelo menos se
dizia na época né
nos dias de hoje seria bullying com
certeza lá que se dizia de estudar
educação física não tem cérebro só tem
músculo né
essa turma e essa professora não estava
preocupada em desfazer esse mito né
não pra esse momento o que nós estávamos
preocupados é em terminar o tc é que a
gente queria terminar o psc dar conta
daquele desafio daquela escolha que a
gente tinha feito por assumir o desafio
que essa professora tinha trazido para a
gente que era pesquisar né
a gente queria era dar conta daquelas
etapas era ler era conseguir escrever né
e fazendo este processo eu me encontro e
encontra uma paixão pesquisar pra mim se
tornou uma paixão pela pesquisa através
da pesquisa eu me descobri descobrir por
novas possibilidades novos rumos para a
minha vida e continuar dando sequência a
essas descobertas essas paixões nada
melhor do que trabalhar com aquilo que a
gente gosta né
com a paixão quando a gente descobre a
paixão de sequência e fui para um
mestrado em educação continua
pesquisando o que movia porque na
verdade na minha formação a gente pode
ver uma linha ekimov né que é a
licenciatura que a escolha por trabalhar
com a escola
o trabalhar com a docência e hoje em dia
então eu faço o doutorado aqui na
unisinos na linha do ppge história da
educação
apaixonada pelas possibilidades que
estão me apresentando pelo doutorado
falando em paixão cobras ler que não é
apaixonado por verde-amarelo né
parece ser uma delegação seria uma
delegação da delegação brasileira de que
essa é a pergunta que era feita
constantemente para esse grupo de jovens
que caminhava pelas ruas de verde
amarelo em los angeles no ano passado
onde esses jovens estariam indo que
iriam fazer em losango
caminhando daquele jeito qualquer
brasileiro caminhando de verde amarelo
em grupo fora é um jogo é uma equipe que
vai jogar alguma coisa né
bom eles estavam indo em a direção
aquela placa que diz lá então o sef né
e essa placa ali afinal o que é então
joseph intel cef é a maior feira de
ciências de jovens de nível de ensino
médio do mundo e nessa feira de ciências
na edição de 2014 só foram apresentados
mais ou menos 1.500 trabalhos e deixa os
1500 trabalhos pode chegar lá os alunos
passam por seletivas nos seus países
ah e só chega lá feiras credenciadas
então a gente está falando sim de uma
seleção brasileira de uma delegação
brasileira de jovens cientistas foram 18
trabalhos levados do ano passado que
representaram o nosso país lá mas a
gente se pergunta é né
várias questões
é pois como eles fizeram chegar lá com
brasileiros transformam cientistas a
educação brasileira forma pra isso que
escolhi eles fizeram estes órgãos
fizeram a escolha de encarar o desafio
proposto pelas suas instituições
escolares
eles tiveram a possibilidade de fazer
essa escolha porque as instituições
propuseram pra eles botaram a disposição
que eles fizessem a pesquisa e
participaram então da maior feira de
ciências da américa latina que é a
mostra tech que é uma das filhas de
ciências que acontece aqui na cidade
vizinha em novo hamburgo que é
credenciado a intel isef edição de 2014
tem os dados ali
essa feira completa este ano 30 anos seu
30º ano de edição
quem organiza essa feira é aquela escola
que era perto da minha casa que foi
induzida trabalhar que eu escolhi trocar
de ramo e que continua trabalhando a
esses alunos aqui foram os alunos
premiados na primeira feira de ciências
desta instituição aqui é onde começa
toda essa história é essa primeira feira
de ciências
acontece eu aconteceu em 1974 e
apreensão desses alunos foi até a cidade
de blumenau
aqui em santa catarina foram acolhidos
por uma família e nessa família foram
acolhidos para conhecer a cidade
estes alunos aqui foi um pouco mais
longe foram a los angeles
essa feira também foi mais longe ela se
tornou uma feira internacional ela
recebe em torno de 20 países
ela recebe alunos do do brasil inteiro
congrega alunos do país inteiro aqui
conosco e também e ela acontece hoje em
dia um dos maiores centros de eventos
ela sai de dentro da escola acontece num
dos maiores centros do evento que é a
fenac em novo hamburgo
no meu doutorado agora na minha mais
nova paixão eu quero é justamente verás
as questões que me movem são como
historicamente uma instituição constrói
uma cultura escolar de ensino baseado na
pesquisa é esse no momento é a minha
mais nova paixão
essa é essa a imagem é empolgante nec
notícia será que este menino recebe que
reage desta forma mais emocionante ainda
a gente vê o vídeo pena que não dá pra
passar aqui a mais ver esse vídeo aqui
vale a pena porque a gente consegue
sentir se pela foto a gente sempre
imagina ver no vídeo
este menino se chama jec andré sica
ele é um menino aqui na foto com 15 anos
ele é um pesquisador americano que
comovido pela doença do tio que era
câncer de pâncreas e pelo fato dos
médicos terem dito que se o câncer de
pâncreas tivesse sido detectado
precocemente
poderia já e como vidro com essa ideia o
jec desenvolve uma pesquisa onde ele
desenvolve um método para detectar
precocemente o câncer de pâncreas que
ele está comemorando aqui
o maior prêmio que ele ganhou na intel
isef de 2012
esse prêmio é relativo
vivo há 75 mil dólares em bolsas de
estudos em financiamentos para ele dar
continuidade à pesquisa dele
isso foi em 2012 a gente acompanhar pela
internet vai ver como ele fez esse
percurso e se emociona na gente faz
mexe com a gente né mas eu me emociono
mais com essa aqui aquele menino lá e
americano a gente sabe que nos estados
unidos eles a incentivam a pesquisa
desde a pré-escola eles têm um
financiamento muito grande pra falar
lidar com pesquisa estes alunos aqui são
brasileiros formados naquela instituição
que foi induzida estudar a estes alunos
aqui foram a menina de vermelho é a
bárbara ela tirou o terceiro lugar na
categoria em que ela concorreu a o
gabriel ea raiz a tiraram o segundo
lugar na categoria em que eles
concorreram na edição de 2014 ea raiz
gabriel no meio dois asteróides que
estão aí no espaço porque foram nessa
edição da interseg efe
quem tirava segundo e primeiro lugar nas
suas categorias nomeavam novos
asteróides que estavam sendo descobertos
por um cientista que já havia passado
pela intel isef eu me emociono muito com
essa imagem aqui e por aí terminando o
que eu queria colocar pra vocês eu deixo
alguma duas perguntas pra gente pensar
um pouquinho
podemos ensinar através da pesquisa
podemos nos apaixonar pelo ato de
pesquisar
era isso que eu queria compartilhar com
vocês muito obrigado